who's ready for another round with the
italian stallion
he may be getting a little long in the
tooth to square off in a boxing ring but
sylvester stallone has never stopped
thinking about rocky balboa
the impact the rocky series has had on
pop culture cannot be understated
it's a true underdog tale that
transcends time and inspires viewers to
get out there and take control of their
lives
the last installment in the saga rocky
balboa was released back in 2006
bringing the boxer's insatiable spirit
to the big screen for a whole new
generation of viewers
that flick saw the geriatric boxer
reunited with apollo creed's former
trainer dupe
and a quick sonic effort to build
strength for one final bout
despite the far-fetched premise the film
actually worked thanks in large part to
the enduring charisma of the franchise's
buff-leading man
at 60 years old many assumed this would
be stallone's last bout in the series
but he's apparently still finding ways
to keep his career defining role present
in the public eye
more recently stallone portrayed a
retired aging rocky for both creed films
as a mentor to michael b jordan's adonis
creed
following the premiere of creed 2
stallone implied he was stepping away
from the role that made him a household
name in a heartfelt instagram post
though he might go back on his word
as i step back because my story has been
told
there's a whole new world that's going
to be opening up
for the audience for this generation
even at 74 years of age the acting
legend has made it known that he isn't
quite ready to close the door on playing
the iconic fighter
whether or not another rocky centric
story will come to fruition remains up
in the air but the rambo actor did share
a piece of exciting news for fans of the
original films
while a new rocky movie would be the
best possible news for fans of the
series a new cut of a classic entry is
pretty much the next best thing
sylvester stallone inadvertently
announced the rocky ford director's cut
via instagram on june 29
2020 after first mentioning it in a post
dedicated to the release of rambo last
blood's extended cut
a commenter asked him if there was a
chance for rocky balboa to get a similar
treatment but stallone said it wasn't in
the works
however in quashing the potential for an
extended cut of the final rocky film he
also spilled the beans on the recut he
was working on to commemorate the fourth
rocky movie's 35th anniversary
some fans might be nervous about any
attempt to tamper with the cinematic
perfection that is rocky
iv but in the words of stallone the cut
so far looks amazing
we'll take the stallion at his word once
that news slipped there was no chance of
stallone jamming the toothpaste back in
the tube
in subsequent posts the actor has
continued to provide sneak peeks into
his editorial process
and insights into what we can expect
from his new cut one such glimpse showed
off some raw footage from rocky iv with
the caption
this is new almost done cut cut snip
snip rocky iv director's cut
another uploaded a day later included a
fun outtake
that same post also encouraged everyone
to interact with both likes and comments
since as stallone put it
you're all part of this journey so let
your voices be heard
it's unknown how different this version
of rocky iv will be from the original
however stallone did hint on instagram
that he intends to delete paulie's robot
from the movie saying in a comment quote
i don't like the robot anymore you're
welcome
it's a nice song it's my favorite
you're the greatest see your sport
see you rocky iv was released in 1985
and rapidly became the most financially
successful film in the long-lived
franchise
even if it weren't a meaningful
anniversary for the film 2020 still
provides an interesting environment for
a new look in an old classic
1980s culture is having a moment if you
haven't noticed
aside from open homages to the neon
decade like netflix's hit supernatural
thriller stranger things and its newly
acquired karate kid sequel cobra kai
a slew of older films and franchises are
now getting a second look
rocky never really left the public's
imagination but the original films are
more relevant than ever thanks to the
success of the creed series which
revisits the legacy of apollo creed a
generation
later much in the same way cobra kai
revisits the legacy of johnny lawrence
it's been a long time since we first saw
chiseled stallone square off against
dolph lundgren's ivan drago
it'll be interesting to see what
stallone's new take adds to the movie's
mythology
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you